ja und jetzt haben die affen pocken auch
deutschland erreicht nach corona jetzt
also auch noch das wie das institut für
mikrobiologie der bundeswehr mitteilte
wurde das virus bei einem patienten
zweifelsfrei nachgewiesen
der patient habe die typisch
veränderungen gezeigt und hier sehen wir
sie auch er seit anfang mai wurden in
mehreren ländern infektionen mit affen
pocken gemeldet etwa in kanada
frankreich den usa und auch in
großbritannien jetzt also auch hier bei
uns in deutschland zugeschaltet ist uns
jetzt philologe klaus stöhr er herr
stöhr wie gefährlich sind affen brocken
denn
der name hört sich sehr dramatisch an
pocken ist natürlich auch wenn das was
vielen menschen einen leichten schauer
über den rücken jagt aber jetzt bomben
den schon sehr lange bekannt spielen bei
den menschen also eigentlich eine gar
keine oder nur sehr geringe rolle anders
in afrika in kongo in nigeria wo in der
kontakt zwischen menschen und primaten
dann viel häufiger und intensiver ist
die primaten und also die achten denn
auch nur so genanntes fehlen wird sind
die russen poliert eigentlich in lagern
dass es die vermutung aber jetzt nicht
nur noch einige mehr fälle als in der
vergangenheit normalerweise sieht man
weniger als dem stelle in europa wo ja
die alle eingeschleppt wurden personen
die aus afrika gekommen sind und die
weiterverbreitung von mensch zu mensch
geschieht dann eigentlich auch extrem zu
selten und dann läuft nicht das
eigentlich aus was man jetzt sieht denn
viele bälle mehr als man in der
vergangenheit gesehen aber es sind immer
noch
zwei hände voll die fälle verlaufen alle
mild in extrem seltenen fällen gibt es
schwere infektionen und da man jetzt
genau hinschaut findet man auch viele
also das hat eine dimension von einer
kroner infektion pandemie oder irgendwas
ähnlichen das kommt jetzt zeitgleich das
ist ein tolles wissenschaftliches
wissenschaftliche beobachtung aber
gesundheitspolitisch ist es gegen gar
nicht wahrscheinlicher dass man vom
blitz erschlagen wird oder im lotto
gewinnen hat dass man auf dem brocken
drucker-hersteller was sind denn die
typischen symptome für affen pocken
unterscheiden sich nicht so sehr von den
eigentlichen punkten man findet diese
bläschen die haben ja schon die bilder
zeigt das ist nicht nur dramatische wie
man gesehen hat wie körper betroffen das
könnte ein bisschen sein dass dann auch
auf platz im blut läuft noch flüssigkeit
heraus fieber gibt normale
virusinfektion also die das ist nicht so
der typische und deswegen ist es nicht
dass die da auch nicht das anschauen für
den patienten in extrem seltenen fällen
auch tatsächlich schwer wiegen er von
der geopolitische von der
weltpolitischen situation ist es vor
allen dingen wichtig dass ich auch eine
meldepflichtige solche dass das erkannt
wird weil weil man angst hat dass
vielleicht die pocken wieder aufstehen
können das virus wurde die menschen
punkten wurde eliminiert
das gibt es aber noch in einigen laboren
da braucht man das noch weiß man noch
bei dem stoff entwickelt müsste und
deswegen ist es so wichtig dass man
jeden fall eigentlich auch dann
untersucht und weiter dann auch meldeten
die whu an die nationalen behörden aber
auch vom wie gesagt aus dem
gesundheitspolitischen
perspektive ist das nicht von bedeutung
aber wenn man solche kleinen push bilden
hat wenn man
nicht unwohl fühlen virale infekte und
das ist ja gerade nicht nur typische
sache dann sollte man auch die akten
sind eigentlich dann schon sehr
aufmerksam und schwere erkrankungen wie
gesagt sehr extrem selten schützt denn
eine pockenimpfung auch waffen packen
wir haben nimmt an dass unter umständen
die abnahme der pocken immunität weil
die impfung ja dann ausgedrückt wurde
nach der ära die kation dass erreger
dann gehen diese nachlassende immunität
eine rolle spielt bei der zunahme der
den affen brocken jetzt beim menschen
das ist aber noch spekulativ die an
seiner stelle sein fach geringer dass
man hier gute schlussfolgerungen dienen
könnte was kann damit zusammenhängen was
wahrscheinlich ist das was wir auch bei
anderen erregern den ökosystemen immer
mehr zusammenlaufen der mehr
kontaktieren und das reisen kommt
natürlich dazu was man jetzt beobachtet
ist dass die weiterverbreitung von
menschen mensch doch mittel öfter
passieren dass man angenommen hatte dass
besonders wahrscheinlich durch
sexualkontakt von homosexuellen männern
die das in die russland weitergeben doch
jetzt zwei fälle in england wie man
gesehen hat es gibt gar keine beziehung
wieder nach afrika noch die anderen mehr
stellen das kann aber auch sein dass man
da was der inhalt das muss man die
nächsten tage abwarten aber wie gesagt
wissenschaftlich hoch interessant aber
weiter zu beobachten von der vom
gesundheitswesen her mit den
einzelpersonen eigentlich irrelevant
theologe klaus t zu den affen pocken
besten dank erste mich bedanken
bild breaking news